ANDREW BROGDON: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to another
episode of the Boring Show.
Today we're mixing
things up a little bit.
Normally it's a couple members
of the DevRel team for Flutter
or the Flutter Engineering
Team, but today
we actually have three different
Google Developer experts
that are in the studio with us.
And you're going to get a
chance to hear from all of them.
And then all four
of us are going
to take your
questions at the end.
So we have a full house
here in the studio.
And we're starting
with Iiro Krankka.
Am I saying that correctly?
IIRO KRANKKA:
That's pretty good.
ANDREW BROGDON: Thank goodness.
And so we're going to be talking
about his InKeno app, which
is one of the sample apps that
we reference in our samples
index about being as a
particularly good model for how
to develop something
that's really big.
And in recent development,
it's now a multi-platform app.
So you are sharing
code between Flutter
and a web app at the same time.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes, exactly.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Which is pretty cool.
And so we're going
to talk about that,
and we're going to talk about
how Redux is working for you.
And just sort of get our
hands dirty with this code
and take a look at it.
So if you would like
to find this app,
you can find it in
the curated samples
index that's part of the
Flutter/samples depot.
The app is called InKeno,
and all the source
is available in
Iiro's GitHub account.
And let's take a look.
So I've got it right here.
Let's take a look at
the web app itself.
So this is your web app.
And this is a recent
development, right?
This came out just recently.
It lists-- actually,
why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what the app does.
IIRO KRANKKA: Well,
basically I built up the app
to scratch my own
itch, because I
live right next to [INAUDIBLE].
And the official app kind of--
there's a lot of improving that.
It takes like five seconds to
even go and see the showtimes.
I was like, well
I'm sitting here,
so why don't I just take a look
and see if I can improve it.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Yeah, be the change.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah, and then
I found out that they actually
have this really
nice modern XMLAPI,
it's not the fanciest
season, but it's still like--
ANDREW BROGDON:
Oh, that's right.
That's another thing that your
app does that not everybody--
a lot of times you're
using JSON so much
and you're actually passing
XML, is really interesting.
So it's a good example
for that reason, as well.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON:
And so you have--
let me pull up.
I've got it running in an
iOS simulator right here.
And so this is just listing
what's in the theaters
right now?
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah, it's listing
what's in Helsinki [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW BROGDON: If anyone
happens to be nearby.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: And so you've
got a listing screen here.
We can go into Spike
Lee's latest thing.
We've got cast
photos and a gallery.
IIRO KRANKKA: Probably
what I usually
do with this app is that
if you go one screen back.
And click on the showtimes
on the bottom navigation.
So you can see what's
currently playing there,
and all those show
times, and you can
see which movies are playing.
And if you click
that yellow button
you can actually buy tickets.
But it's redirecting.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK, so you're
doing the URL launcher probably
packaged to get out?
IIRO KRANKKA: Exactly.
ANDREW BROGDON: Awesome.
It looks like you've got a
sliver app bar at the top,
I'm guessing?
IIRO KRANKKA: No that's
actually something--
I didn't know about
sliver app bars
back then when I first did this,
so this is something like--
ANDREW BROGDON: You
just custom wrote it.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Awesome.
IIRO KRANKKA: Don't
look at the code.
ANDREW BROGDON: I have
a lot of code that way.
But this is great.
OK, let's look at the code here.
OK, so the main point here
is that like across those--
did you actually
show the web app?
So that's for web as well.
So when you can show the
sometimes on the web, as well.
Click on the details page.
IIRO KRANKKA: This is the
web version of the screen
that I was just
looking at basically.
Yes, exactly.
So it's on the web as well.
It's responsive, so it's a
progressive web app, as well.
So the web app works offline.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh
wow, that's nice.
IIRO KRANKKA: And It works
in a mobile device as well.
And you can install that to
your home screens as well.
And the main thing is that I'm
serving like 40 percent of code
between those two apps.
ANDREW BROGDON: So 40%.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's
a nice time saving.
OK.
And so let's go back in here.
This is the mobile--
this is the Flutter app itself.
And then you have
core, which is--
IIRO KRANKKA:
[INAUDIBLE] Secrets.
Is he blowing the screen?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, I
just leaked an API key.
So that'll get blurred
in post-production.
My bad on that one.
You have a core
that's a shared code.
Let's just close this file here.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: This is
shared between the two, right?
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Then you
have a web project here
that has additional code
for the web presenentation.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah, this
is basically the main entry
point for the web app.
ANDREW BROGDON: And this
is written in Dart as well?
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK,
do you love Dart?
I see an NG in here.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah,
it's Anglo darts.
It was actually pretty
cool to do that.
ANDREW BROGDON: Nice.
Well let's take a look real
quick at the mobile project.
I'm curious.
So you use Redux just as your
state management for this.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: And I know we
get a lot of state management
questions.
People are wondering about
the various approaches
because Flutter isn't
opinionated in that way.
You can sort of do
it however you want.
Let's talk about
that real quick.
So where is the Redux code.
Is that in core?
IIRO KRANKKA: It's in the core.
So basically what
we didn't discuss
is that I have three projects.
So one is the core project,
which has all that business
logic, all the shared code.
Then we have mobile project,
which is this other project,
and then we have web,
which is the Angular code.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK, so you
would have Angular code
sort of managing presentation
of the core stuff for the web?
IIRO KRANKKA: Well, yeah.
So the Angular
project imports core
in the web project and
the mobile project,
which is Flutter,
imports also the code.
ANDREW BROGDON: And then sort
of makes widgets out of it,
I imagine.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
So the goal is to keep
the UI layers as dumb
and lean as possible and have
all the logic in the core.
ANDREW BROGDON: Cool.
IIRO KRANKKA: So you
will probably have--
this is the core, this is
the [INAUDIBLE],, TMDB, API.
This Is probably not the most
interesting process here.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
What can I pull up?
Where's something that's
making a reducer or somethign
ike that?
IIRO KRANKKA: Probably only
the theater, or actor or--
ANDREW BROGDON: Here?
IIRO KRANKKA: For
example, that one.
ANDREW BROGDON: So this
is Middleware for Redux.
IIRO KRANKKA: For the theater
listing, this is that one.
ANDREW BROGDON: So let's see.
IIRO KRANKKA: So there's a
lot of career- related to--
for example, if you live
right next to Helsinki,
then it's [INAUDIBLE].
And you use that the first
time when you open the app.
You don't want to do that
every time you open the app.
So it's persisting
that to locally.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK
IIRO KRANKKA: So that every
time you open the app,
it remembers stuff.
And that's actually
interesting part of this.
So if you can go to
the [INAUDIBLE] point
of the Flutter or web app.
The main file.
Yeah, here.
So basically here's
the function code--
like, on 17th line.
If you come and click
on the Create Store.
Oh.
OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me
go to the mobile one.
I'll probably have
an easier time
navigating through the code.
IIRO KRANKKA: Well, but it might
be that it doesn't work here.
Like, I set up
something special for--
OK, awesome.
So this is basically the code
that creates the Redux store.
And it takes in the client
and key value store.
And this is the
thing that you will
encounter when you're sharing
code between web and mobile.
So if you want to
purchase something,
Android has shared preferences.
ANDREW BROGDON: Right.
IIRO KRANKKA: IS has
NS user defaults.
And web has local stores.
And how do you--
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, we've
sort of got that worked out.
In the world of mobile,
we have the local storage,
which will handle the
details of mapping to IOS
storage and Android storage.
IIRO KRANKKA: You mean serve
preference the blogging?
ANDREW BROGDON: There you go.
IIRO KRANKKA: I'm
using that on mobile.
ANDREW BROGDON: But that
doesn't help you on the web.
You have to come up
with your own thing.
IIRO KRANKKA: You cannot import
Flutter in the core module.
And you cannot import
web into core module.
So how do you do that?
Basically here-- this is the
way you create the Redux store.
And it takes in the
key value store.
And this is actually
packets that I made.
So key value store
is an absolute class
that defines the interface for
storing key and value fares.
And then on the web, I have
a web implementation of that.
And on the mobile, we have a
mobile implementation of that.
So if you go back to
the main dodge file
that you have open
there, it's in the--
other.
ANDREW BROGDON: One up
IIRO KRANKKA: We inject
Flutter key value store here.
ANDREW BROGDON: It fills
out this interface.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: And it's
using shared prefs there.
IIRO KRANKKA: So this is
the Flutter project and we--
in the main entry
point of that, we
insect Flutter key
value store, which
is basically delegating all the
calls to shared preferences.
And on the web project we
have the same set up going on.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
IIRO KRANKKA: I made
a plug-in for this.
I mean, the library.
And it's published
on [INAUDIBLE]..
I didn't advertise it just yet.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
So is it a Dart package
rather than a Flutter package?
IIRO KRANKKA: It's
actually three packages.
ANDREW BROGDON: Of course.
IIRO KRANKKA: So
one package just
for the app set class, and one
packet just for the Flutter
implementation, and
one for the web.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's really
great that you open sourced it,
then somebody else can
come along and use it.
I have a feeling
we're going to start
getting more questions
about reusing code
as Dart as a language,
I think, progresses
and gets more popular.
I think we're going
to start seeing
more questions like this.
Interesting.
IIRO KRANKKA: Is
there anything else?
ANDREW BROGDON: That
what I was about.
So we covered that.
We talked about looking at a
reducer in core too, right?
So a fairly simple one.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: So let's see.
You've got-- Theater Reducer.
So you're checking
the action type here.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: And then are
your state objects immutable?
I see you're using Copy With.
IIRO KRANKKA: That's
just a manual thing
that I did because I
didn't want to use field
value for this project
because this is supposed
to be a sample project.
And I already have like
Redux, Flutter, Angukar, Dot.
ANDREW BROGDON: You have a few
dependencies involved already?
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
So I wanted to--
so that people can
just clone it and just
start running it as
easy as possible.
But basically,
what [INAUDIBLE] is
like-- it takes in current
state and an action,
and returns a new state.
So if there's an action,
it knows to handle handler,
it will update
the current state.
Or otherwise it will
just return the kernel.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
IIRO KRANKKA: What do you find
more most interesting in this?
Because, like, I've been looking
at this for a couple of months
now, so I'm kind
of deep into it--
ANDREW BROGDON: I
think there are details
here that you would
have run into that I'm
curious how you solved.
I assume you're
using Redux.dart.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: The
sort of standard Redux
the implementation
that's out there.
And I think Brain even works on,
along with some other people.
What about something
like routing?
How do you handle that
within Flutter, for example?
So say you're sitting on
this theater listening
that you have-- let me
pull it back up real quick.
So you're sitting here--
IIRO KRANKKA: The
listening is actually
on the main place marker.
So that's on the other listing.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
What about the movie listing
that you have to start?
Down here.
So if I tap on one
of these, I'm going
to go to a separate screen.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Right.
Have you already loaded all
of the data for that screen?
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
So that's how the [INAUDIBLE]
nice XML [INAUDIBLE] works.
It just throws all
the data that it has.
There's no--
ANDREW BROGDON: Here's
a giant XML file.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
Good luck with that.
So I already have
the event object.
So just pass that
to the next route.
ANDREW BROGDON:
That's interesting.
So how do you pass
this giant XML file?
Do you do that in another
isolate or anything like that?
Or do you do it asynchronously?
IIRO KRANKKA: It has had
been working quite well
just doing it in the same
thread that I'm currently in.
So I didn't have to use any
isolates or anything like that.
it works quite fine without it.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Interesting, because that's
in the Vox [INAUDIBLE]
that we've been working on,
there are issues where I want
to go to a different screen--
so obviously Flutter
supports that very well.
You have a navigator widget
that you can push routes to.
But then how do you remember,
oh I'm on the details screen
now for this particular
session at a conference.
I might need to refresh that
data and go make a JSON call.
And that was something
that that app needed
to do that it sounds like
you, because of the way
the back end was
designed, you just
didn't even have to worry
about it, which is nice.
IIRO KRANKKA: There's no
way to me to do that even.
Like, I cannot do it.
It's a fun little API.
For example, if you go
the event name cleaner.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh, that's
a fun name for a file.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: What do we have?
I see rejects.
IIRO KRANKKA: And the
best case for that, it's
in the test folder, so you can--
there's a lot of
funny stuff going on.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's good.
Yeah, how are you
testing this actually?
IIRO KRANKKA: If you go to the
YouTube folder and see there.
Yeah, that's one.
ANDREW BROGDON: So many tests.
You're so much more
disciplined than I am.
IIRO KRANKKA: So, for
example, this one is like--
it's a finicky API returns.
It thinks that like Avengers
Infinity War 2D, and 3D,
and 2D dub and 2D original
are different movies.
Which means that if you go
to the movie poster create,
you will get six same posters.
So I had to do this.
That cleans up all the noise,
and so it normalizes the names.
And there's a lot of
these cases, because it--
ANDREW BROGDON: Always happens.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON:
It's always happens.
IIRO KRANKKA: I already
added a lot of cases there.
ANDREW BROGDON: They have
the sing along for Mamma Mia.
IIRO KRANKKA: Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: Nice.
IIRO KRANKKA: And sing along
is different than the Mamma Mia
original, you know?
ANDREW BROGDON:
That's the one where
you go and the audience gets
to be loud and sing along
with the songs?
IIRO KRANKKA: I don't know.
I never went there.
ANDREW BROGDON: Maybe
somebody in the comments
can let us know, I think
that's how it works.
IIRO KRANKKA: I don't
have a girlfriend,
so nobody is making
me go into those.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
I think we're about
done with our segment.
I really appreciate you spending
some time with us today.
Is there anything else you think
other developers should know?
Let's tell them.
IIRO KRANKKA: I'm
going to just say
that it was a fun
experience to do that.
We're doing that
as work, as well.
It's open source,
so check it out.
And I feel like it's actually
really, really good reference.
And I'm going to do an
article series about it.
ANDREW BROGDON: Excellent.
IIRO KRANKKA: So I think you
can put the link somewhere
in the box down there
or something like that.
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure, we will.
Yeah, like I said,
this is a really good--
as you can see from the
size this code base,
Iiro is doing some things
that are definitely
models for how other
app developers might
want to do them.
So if you're using
Redux, if you're
sharing code between
the web and mobile,
if you want to see some
very well-made tests,
by the looks of it, this
looks like a great sample.
You can find it on GitHub
under Fluttersesh/samples.
It's in our index, and thanks
for coming on the show.
IIRO KRANKKA: Thanks for--
it's awesome to be
awesomely boring.
Thanks.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yes it is.
All right, so we're going
to take a real quick break.
And we're going to bring in our
next expert in just a second.
All right so we switched
up the seating now.
I'm here with Pawan Kumar,
Google developer expert
in Flutter, whom you may
know from YouTube and GitHub.
And our curated list of
samples on the samples
repo you make an appearance.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: You
have a whole bunch
of Flutter example apps here.
A lot of good UI stuff.
There's a lot of UI layer--
however you want
to present things,
you can probably find
an example in this repo.
There's a ton of stuff.
And, of course, you also
make your own videos.
PAWAN KUMAR: Correct.
ANDREW BROGDON: Under
the name Mtechviral.
You have, I think, more videos
than I have made for Flutter.
You have dozens?
PAWAN KUMAR: No, hundreds.
ANDREW BROGDON: Hundreds.
PAWAN KUMAR: We have
around 120 Flutter videos,
and around more than
10 dot videos, then
10 plus fire based videos with
Flutter, so a lot of stuff.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's a lot.
You have almost 18,000
subscribers and so on.
So much like--
I would recommend taking a
look at his Github samples.
Also Mtechviral on YouTube.
Highly recommended.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah,
you should watch it.
ANDREW BROGDON: And so
you've got something
that you coded up just
for us today, right?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes, yes.
So these are very small things,
which I wanted to just to color
because when we make any
project we miss some stuff.
And because of
these things we have
to use a lot of other
widgets to achieve this.
But we can achieve it
in a very easy way.
So that's what I
wanted to cover.
So this is our menu page.
So if you can just--
ANDREW BROGDON: Start on
commenting bodies here?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: Which one
do you recommend first?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
So you have to import it.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Sure, no problem.
PAWAN KUMAR: [INAUDIBLE]
Like this, maybe.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah I can.
PAWAN KUMAR: So,
as you can see--
OK.
So in a row, if we
have multiple widgets,
then you can see that
the overflow exception.
ANDREW BROGDON: The
black and yellow,
yeah I'm angry l kind
of thing from Flutter.
PAWAN KUMAR: So suppose we have
like four items in one row.
And there can be
scenarios where we
don't want to make those
items appear in the next line
or maybe somewhere else.
We just want them
in the single line.
And in those items,
Flutter's box
is going to be a
very good widget.
So if it just--
you sample and then
it's just put SOL--
S-O-L-- after this.
ANDREW BROGDON: Let
me shrink this up
a little bit so we can see it--
PAWAN KUMAR: Much better.
So here you have to write SOL.
Capital S and OL.
ANDREW BROGDON: Like that?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
And just import that.
Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: So this
is the fixed version.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes, this
ANDREW BROGDON: Well, hold on.
Let's real quick,
let's go into this
and see the code that
we were using before.
So there's a row up here.
PAWAN KUMAR: There's
a row up here.
ANDREW BROGDON: And
just raised button
sized box, just
like you would do
if you were
confident you weren't
going to run out of space.
PAWAN KUMAR: Correct.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
PAWAN KUMAR: So, then
if you'll just show--
ANDREW BROGDON: This
is the solution, then.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
And now you can see,
everything is fixed,
and everything is one line.
So I will add just to the
widgets inside it itself.
So that can be pretty
handy because sometimes you
don't want to actually use
multiple lines for showing
those widgets maybe because
you have small phones and maybe
other stuff.
ANDREW BROGDON: So you fix this
with one additional widget?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah, just one.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Just one fitted box.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah,
just one fitted box.
And you can specify the
fit type as well here.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Oh, that's right.
There's a property here.
PAWAN KUMAR: It has a property.
ANDREW BROGDON:
And it's a box fit?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes, so
it can be very useful.
I have used it a lot.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
I've definitely abuse fitted
box with images and icons
before, I have not tried using
it with a whole row of thing.
PAWAN KUMAR: So there's a
repository for the Flutter UI
kit where there was a card
section-- credit card section--
and when you enter some
text into that text field,
that it gets populated
inside that credit card.
And that was working fine,
but for small devices,
there were some issues, right?
And even if you are
using the media quality
to get the size,
then also you don't
want to actually have
those credit card
numbers in the next line.
So in that scenario, fitted
box was very helpful for me.
So desk size was
reduced a little bit,
but because the phone
size is also small,
it kind of works pretty well.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK, yeah.
So I've yet to see a
credit card where it wraps
the number to the next line.
PAWAN KUMAR: Correct.
So the UI was not
looking good after that,
so it's much better to
use this fitted box.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
Let's see.
is.
So there's a row sample?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah,
so this row sample.
If you just refresh it,
it's the same thing.
ANDREW BROGDON: Same thing?
PAWAN KUMAR: But the thing is,
we don't want to-- you can say
compress those things--
we want to show them
maybe in the next line,
either vertically
or horizontally.
So it depends.
So you can just do that with
the wrap widget, which can be,
again, very useful.
ANDREW BROGDON: Is there a
solution for this one as well?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: Not just
a hat rack, my friends.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
PAWAN KUMAR: So you can
see, this looks really well.
And it works also a la carte.
You can use wrap for anything.
And it has all the
same properties,
which our column has so.
It kind of works.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's right.
You have alignment
properties as well?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes, yes.
It has the alignment.
ANDREW BROGDON: Direction,
alignment spacing.
PAWAN KUMAR: REM
spacing as well, so--
ANDREW BROGDON: So if I wanted
to come in here and say,
does it take an inster?
PAWAN KUMAR: It should
take a double, maybe?
ANDREW BROGDON: So I
could come in and say,
I want a whole bunch of
spacing between my widgets,
and I can space
them out like that.
PAWAN KUMAR: And it
looks kind of cool.
And you don't have
to do anything right.
You don't have to use some other
widgets for doing this task.
You don't have to use expander
and flexible so that--
ANDREW BROGDON: Or inject
a bunch of padding.
PAWAN KUMAR: Padding is
also one thing I would
like people to avoid because--
ANDREW BROGDON: I see you're
using sized boxes to space
these out yourself like I used.
PAWAN KUMAR: Size boxes are
always good because sometimes--
it also makes your code
cleaner so that's what I feel.
So try to avoid padding
as much as you can, right?
ANDREW BROGDON: Definitely
when spacing out things
within a single direction
list, I prefer size box.
This has been a matter
of some discussion.
PAWAN KUMAR: Correct.
ANDREW BROGDON: Around
the Flutter team,
actually, because
a lot of people
prefer using padding
whenever possible.
PAWAN KUMAR: I don't
know, I prefer box a lot.
Then we have this banner widget.
I don't know of the user
fed, but we kind of fused it.
So, as you can see,
there's no solution.
That's just one sample.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh,
this is just a problem?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah.
So you can see this can
be helpful like this.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh, so is
this the banner down here?
PAWAN KUMAR: So there's
a widget for when if
you go inside this--
but now you can.
Ass this to location, as well.
It kind of looks fancy, I guess.
ANDREW BROGDON: This has got
to be the widget that they
did the debug banner with.
And they were just like,
if we had to make it,
we'll give it to everybody else.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah,
so actually one guy
asked me that there's a
debug ribbon on the top--
how to use that free one.
I just sliced about it
and the repository itself,
and I got the banner widget.
So I thought, maybe, it
can be useful for if you
are making a gift
application or something.
ANDREW BROGDON: Can you put--
I wonder-- can you
put a [INAUDIBLE] Do
you know if that works?
I'm curious.
PAWAN KUMAR: I believe so.
It should work.
Because, that's the beauty of--
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, we're
supposed to compose things out
of other things.
PAWAN KUMAR: So let's
see if that works.
ANDREW BROGDON: So it should
if I bring my log backup.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah, it's working.
Awesome.
ANDREW BROGDON:
And is it doing--
So I end up with--
I do end up it looks like
with some hit detection.
PAWAN KUMAR: And you can change
the location, as well, right?
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
So it's using a
container in the banner.
PAWAN KUMAR: I mean,
you can use anything.
I just use container.
Maybe people can
use anything else.
So I just wanted to show that
we are in the Boring Development
show.
So I just used this image.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
PAWAN KUMAR: So now we can
do the other one, maybe.
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me
go ahead and hide this.
PAWAN KUMAR: And then
we have this IOS sample,
which is kind of on another
widget which I use a lot
because sometimes you cannot
use a stack every day.
So you can see.
This overlay can be helpful
when you want to show something
on the top of everything.
So there's a messenger
which shows the chat
head on the top of the screens.
So similarly, this is an
in-app thing, but again,
can be very useful
and you're onto--
some people does not like snap
bar a lot in their bottom,
so if you want to show
something on the top
in the formal snap bar,
then also it's very useful.
Maybe you want to show
some alert or something.
ANDREW BROGDON: Where does this?
So this is show overlay.
There are a lot of show
something top level functions.
Like, Show Search is one.
PAWAN KUMAR: Is this the
name off still matter?
ANDREW BROGDON: And so is this--
OK, so this is--
PAWAN KUMAR: So you
have some overlay state.
And you have to
provide the context
to that particular
widget, and then it
takes on all the entries.
You can have multiple
entries as well.
I'm just doing one thing.
I'm just using this future
to delay by two seconds,
and then I'm just removing
it from the state.
So that's simple.
And you don't have
to use stacks,
otherwise it's kind
of very difficult
if you want to show some things.
And here you can just
use a pollution widget
and you can maybe
add just a little bit
of that wherever you want to
show that particular banner
or something.
So I personally use it a
lot for one of my project.
ANDREW BROGDON: I wonder--
so you're using an overlay.ov
to get the overlay.
So there's an inherited overlay.
PAWAN KUMAR: Correct.
ANDREW BROGDON: It must
be provided as part--
provided as part
of material app.
PAWAN KUMAR: Correct.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
PAWAN KUMAR: And we have one
more widget if we can use that,
once I can't.
So you can see the
last [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW BROGDON: I think
we have a couple here.
PAWAN KUMAR: First we will
see this spacer sample.
And that would be
much better because we
have to change the Cupertino.
You can see we have just
the-- can you go back
and go to the code?
Yes.
So here you can see we
have these two buttons,
but now we want some
spacing between them, right?
We want one on the left and
second one one the right.
So this can be a
little bit tricky
if you don't know about
the widgets, right?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah
I would come in here
and like do an expanded here.
But I don't think
that would get me--
like I could do rapid new
widget and do expanded,
but I think that's just going
to make this an enormous button,
which I don't want, right?
PAWAN KUMAR: So you can just
add a spacer in between them.
Just try to do that.
And just let's see what
happens as it refreshed.
It's not refreshed, I guess.
ANDREW BROGDON: Bend to my will.
I will relaunch you.
Just in case.
PAWAN KUMAR: So maybe it
will take a few minutes.
Not an issue.
ANDREW BROGDON: These
things happen all the time
on the show.
It's fine.
Let's see, so that's spacer.
PAWAN KUMAR: I guess
it just stopped.
ANDREW BROGDON: I don't
know what the simulator is
doing right now.
PAWAN KUMAR: I guess
I should kill it once.
ANDREW BROGDON: Can we do that?
OK.
PAWAN KUMAR: Lot of apps.
ANDREW BROGDON: Various
things that we're
running at one point.
PAWAN KUMAR: It can
be an issue, right?
ANDREW BROGDON:
In the meantime--
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah,
in the meantime.
ANDREW BROGDON: So we have this.
PAWAN KUMAR: It should work.
ANDREW BROGDON: So I assume that
was the solution right there
just to put this
little thing in.
PAWAN KUMAR: That's the
solution-- simple solution.
Just use a spacer.
And you can use multiple
spacers, as well.
ANDREW BROGDON: So is it
just an expanded, basically,
with an empty container inside?
PAWAN KUMAR: And you can
maybe give a flex, as well.
ANDREW BROGDON: You
can set the flex.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes,
as you can see.
So kind of thing
happened with me
where I wanted to
have two buttons--
one on the left,
one on the right.
And I was figuring out what's
the easiest solution for that.
The cleaner solution, maybe.
So it was--
ANDREW BROGDON: One
widget with no properties.
It's hard to get much
clearer than that.
OK.
PAWAN KUMAR: OK,
one more widget,
which I selected a lot
of widgets, but let's
talk about because it's kind
of useful as super simple.
And I just want you
to go in the top.
ANDREW BROGDON: Here?
PAWAN KUMAR: On the top.
On the top.
And just change it to
material app to Cupertino app.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh, of course.
PAWAN KUMAR: And just change
the home as well to Cupertino
sample-- cupersample.
And then I guess we can see--
ANDREW BROGDON: We're
going to have to.
PAWAN KUMAR: Stop.
You have to go to
this cupersample now.
It's not that one.
It's called cupersample soil.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's OK.
The one that works.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes.
So now I just want
to show this way.
Like, if you will
just try to scroll.
And this kind of
things you can achieve.
Someone asked me--
he was looking
at the App Store in the iPhone,
and it had this kind of effect.
So he asked me, will
it take some time.
And he was trying to do it
without using any widget.
He was trying to actually make
all of these things by himself.
He was giving the
font size, as well.
It was very hectic for him.
So I introduced him with
this Cupertino widget.
So there are a lot of widgets.
If you go to cupersample sol.
Then I guess there's
a lot of options here.
I don't think that we have time
to actually color all of them.
ANDREW BROGDON: No, not if we're
going to get to Observatory.
PAWAN KUMAR: I'll
make a video on that.
I already have two minutes.
I guess we can also
take for Observatory.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Yeah let's just--
PAWAN KUMAR: Let's
open Observatory.
I guess that's the
symbol for that.
Yes.
So if you'll go do
this Isolate main dot.
ANDREW BROGDON: Just
real quick, for anybody
who has never hit that button
or the link that gets spit out
by Flutter.
PAWAN KUMAR: It's kind
of very useful stuff.
So you should at
least take a look.
Just go to your main dot,
this isolated window dot.
And in the bottom, if you'll
just scroll, you can see these.
There are some indications
like green and red.
So these green ones are those
which are actually executed.
And these red ones are the
lines which are not executed,
so it can become kind of useful.
So you can just go to
this cupersample sol.
I guess, if we can find it.
ANDREW BROGDON: Cupertino
solution right there.
PAWAN KUMAR: So you
can just go there
and you can see these
lines were executed.
It is very useful
for me sometimes.
And I don't know,
maybe it can be useful
for others as well
because by debugging
it kind of helps a lot.
And there's hard restart
and all this stuff.
I have covered it in
my video, so maybe.
And one more thing I just
wanted to mention before you
end this--
So, can we go to that
[INAUDIBLE],, this one.
ANDREW BROGDON: It's
the Boring-- this one?
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes,
so Boring Show.
OK, let's click on
that in the bottom.
So these are some tools.
JSON to dart.
I guess this is the
website where you can just
paste your JSON, and it will
create the mono pass for you.
ANDREW BROGDON: I've
seen this before.
PAWAN KUMAR: Because
not everybody
wants to use those scripts
to generate those classes.
So it works pretty well.
ANDREW BROGDON: So you can do
something like this-- field.
PAWAN KUMAR: So I have that
second link for this only.
So if you want to
have something.
OK it will work.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh, no.
PAWAN KUMAR: There
was some issue.
ANDREW BROGDON: Probably
doesn't like my quotes.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes,
can be one thing.
ANDREW BROGDON: The
tyranny of double quotes.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes, it's working.
It kind of works pretty well.
I have used a lot.
So these are some tools.
I know we have a lot to cover,
but we cannot cover it right
now.
ANDREW BROGDON: We're
about out of time.
But thank you, especially
for putting together
such great code examples,
along with all the other things
you've done to help
the Flutter community.
PAWAN KUMAR: And
it is open source,
so you can check it out.
If there's some stuff, as well--
some other stuff,
like future as well.
How to use it.
So they can take a
look at how to check
the connections if is waiting
and you have some data or not.
So that's included in that
strip for Boring Show.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
PAWAN KUMAR: So maybe
that can be helpful.
Thanks for having me here.
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
PAWAN KUMAR: A
pleasure to be here.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right,
so does it with Pawan Kumar.
Again, check out N Tech
Viral, check out his samples.
You can find them in
the Flutter/sample repo.
And we're going to move
on to our next GDE.
PAWAN KUMAR: And please
subscribe to the channel, mine
as well.
And this one, as well.
Thank you.
ANDREW BROGDON: There you go.
Hey everybody.
We're back with our
third expert today,
Eugenio Marletti, which
is Italian I want to say?
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Originally, yes.
Excellent.
ANDREW BROGDON: And you
have something pretty
unusual to show us today.
You have a game that
you have written.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yes, I mean
no copyright infringement.
ANDREW BROGDON: Of course.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
But there was a game
once that was a viral
success, Flappy Bird.
ANDREW BROGDON: Of course.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: And of course
it's sort of a rite of passage
to write that into
whatever framework it's in.
ANDREW BROGDON: It's the
new Hello World, right?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Pretty much.
And so I thought it
would be fun to do it
in Flutter with a few twists.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
OK.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: So
the very first twist
is that I remade the graphics
of the bird, which is Dart now.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh,
so you made a dash.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah, sorry.
A dash.
And the Dash version.
It's modeled after
a Dash version.
I use this really cool pixel
art editor called Ace Bright.
And it does a gif.
ANDREW BROGDON: Shams,
our tech writer,
who designed Dash
and the plushies.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: You
can see the frames
if you go up and down.
ANDREW BROGDON: So
it's the flapping.
OK.
Yeah.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: And
then when he dies,
he can also do the flapping.
And the eye is the same
as the Chrome dinosaur.
When he dies, you know,
has the eyes like that.
So that's the first twist.
The other is that I didn't use--
I didn't want to
use any game engine.
This is widgets.
Not even render objects,
widgets all the way down.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Interesting experiment.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: So,
like if you imagine maybe
you can like--
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me
go and run this once.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Perfect, yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON:
And, of course, I'm
running this on a
simulator, so I'm not
going to get quite
the performance we
would on a real device.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Yeah, of course.
ANDREW BROGDON: Which I'll
blame my my poor performance
in the game on.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah, no.
It's super smooth in release.
But so essentially we have--
games normally have
this loop where
you have ticks and every step.
Yeah.
ANDREW BROGDON: I
think I hit the--
so I'm going through pipes.
Is that by design?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: So
the collision detection
is not done yet.
So I put like a
fixed cap, otherwise
it would skyrocket to infinity
because the acceleration is
really strong.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Because it turns out
it's not using
realistic gravity.
I had to reverse engineer how
it is, but it's not realistic.
It's way stronger
than you would think.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: And so
what you've seen-- can
you hit play again so I can
show you the layout, generally.
ANDREW BROGDON: So you've got
some stream controllers in here
I can see.
You've got sprites coming
from the widget up here.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Essentially,
I created a widget class that
holds an image that it
already carries along
information like this size
and other things like that.
So even before
loading the image,
you already know
that ratio, and it's
a lot easier for the
layout to work that way.
Everything can be
automated real time.
For now I wrote it by hand.
That's whatever.
And so what you see here
is one scrolling container.
The bird is actually fixed.
ANDREW BROGDON:
This is very much
in the don't try
this at home veins.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Try it.
ANDREW BROGDON: Sort
of experimental.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: But it's using
things that are very normal.
So instead of having
this classic ticking
loop of the game, we have a
ticker attached to the widget.
ANDREW BROGDON: So like
the animation ticker?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Exactly.
So at every frame,
we essentially
calculate the next step.
Not even by hand.
The system does it for us.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's what it's
normally doing for animations.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: And
then the whole thing
is a scrolling container
and the scrolling is not
done by gestures.
But it's done by the ticking.
ANDREW BROGDON: Every tick
you scroll a little bit.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Literally.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
The bird is falling
with the simulation of
course, because that's
the physics we use, which
is the internal simulation
class of Flutter.
And I just wrote a different
gravity kind of simulation
to make it fall.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Are you rotating?
Do you have like a rotating box?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah, exactly.
It's rotating with a
rotation transformation.
I think I'm going
to try another one.
What else?
It's going up and
down in translation.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK, so this is
your moving bird widget which,
represents Dash on the screen.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: So
also interesting there,
even there the bird is
composed by wrapping.
So there's like the static
bird, the flapping and then
the moving, essentially.
And it's widgets nested
one into each other.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh my goodness.
OK, so Moving Bird.
Is that just the bird on screen?
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
And it's literally--
it's fixed.
If you really look at
it, the world is moving
and the bird is fixed.
So it's all relative, right.
ANDREW BROGDON: Bird offset
Y would be the height, right?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Exactly, yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: Moving
Bird State is not
something I anticipated seeing.
Yeah, this is very
similar to how you
would do any other animation.
You have Single Ticker
Provider, state mix in which
provides the frame signals.
If we're going 60
frames per second,
you'd get one of these
every 16,000ths of a second.
And redraw.
Flaps Subscription.
Fall Velocity after.
That.
So this is pixels
per second squared.
That's awesome.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Clearly.
ANDREW BROGDON: And yet valid.
And so where is your build?
You've got this
state for widgets.
You've got have a build in here.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah, so it
calculates just a few things,
but then this is a
very simple widget.
ANDREW BROGDON: At the end of
the day, you're it's transform?
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
We start from center
of this column, let's say.
Right from the ground,
if I'm not mistaken
to the top of the screen.
And then from there, we
just apply a translation
and a rotation
based on the values
of the physics at that moment.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh, you've
got a custom paint in here.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: I do.
I don't remember why.
ANDREW BROGDON: So it's
a custom paint of birds.
This is the bird.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: It
might have something
to do with refreshing.
No, I think that was--
this is in progress thing
for making it flap.
I believe, but I'm
not entirely sure.
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me
close out some assets
that I had opened here.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: It's
supposed to be right under.
ANDREW BROGDON: So moving
bird back down here.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: It
should repaint as always.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: I think
there was either a bug
or I wasn't using
something properly,
and it wasn't
repainting sometimes.
ANDREW BROGDON: So this
moving bird accepts a bird.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Clearly.
ANDREW BROGDON: You're
injecting the bird.
And then this is--
if I go back to Main, I
guess, would I find something?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Oh, this
is also an interesting one.
Since the original
game is very much
fixed on one sided
dimensions, it
doesn't rescale on
tablets or anything.
I kind of want to do the
same, so what we're doing
is we're drawing
this at size one.
And then we're putting
it inside a fitted,
so that it just scales and
fills the screen by maintaining
the aspect ratio.
ANDREW BROGDON:
The game widgets.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: We
put the on the borders--
the red.
Let's say in cuts by using
a decorator widget just
to change the background.
And as a nice touch, we also
change the Chrome to be light.
So on Android, for
example, you would
see that light icon and text
and stuff in the status bar.
ANDREW BROGDON: So where
are you doing that?
Are you using System Chrome
to do that back in May?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: May, I think.
ANDREW BROGDON: There it is.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: There you go.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, I
always try to call those out.
System Chrome-- a lot
of handy stuff in there
for just a little bit of polish.
When I did the
reverse Flutter flip,
I didn't want to
do a landscape UI,
and so I used System Chrome to
just say, you're in portrait.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: That's a hack.
ANDREW BROGDON: That's
where you will stay.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Oh
another cute thing--
I disabled the
Debug mode banner.
And instead inserted my
own-- the game banner.
So you know exactly.
ANDREW BROGDON: So
the banner widget,
heretofore unused
on the Boring Show,
has now made two
appearances today.
Interesting.
Every time I see this I'm
reminded of the old fork
this on GitHub banners that
used to be on every web.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
It's absolutely that.
ANDREW BROGDON: And have fallen
out of style a little bit,
I guess.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
But I really wanted
this to feel sort of
looks like a hack project,
but it's actually an example
of how to be build apps.
And so even the banner is like
just a joke on the whole topic.
What else do we have?
Yeah, there's sounds by using--
ANDREW BROGDON:
That's a good deal.
How are you doing sounds?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: This is the
only real dependency we have,
unfortunately, because there's
still nothing in the framework
directly.
So there is one library
called Older Players,
if I'm not mistaken.
And so, again, here,
you need a bundle
to find the sounds anywhere.
And so you inject that, but once
you do it, you can play a sound
and recreate it in that
justice to make it easier
to play the sounds.
Right now they're
still not wired up,
but this is how you
would call them.
You essentially
have a sounds object
and just say sound
play that, play that.
And everything is
injected all the way down.
So from the assets that you
could swap if you wanted to,
you can inject--
I mean, of course, the
sounds and everything.
And it's super detectable.
ANDREW BROGDON: So
this is the package
that you're using, right?
The audio package.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: That
is the package, yes.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Which funnily enough,
I think was created for games.
ANDREW BROGDON: It's a
general truth anything
that people develop for software
will be used for a game.
You go back in the
'60s, you see people
that programmed their
Osciloscopes to play things.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Because
it's surprising how hard it
is to play sounds concurrently.
Like having overlapping sounds,
and this is one of the few--
at least at the time
when I wrote this,
one of the few libraries
that allowed to actually do
overlapping sounds, which,
of course, is really much
needed in the game.
What else do we have?
Yeah, another very interesting
aspect is the pipes
are random the way they
come into the screen.
ANDREW BROGDON: So the
spacing between the pipes
is fixed, but where--
the break that you
have to flap through.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Exactly, and so what I do
is that I created a
random generator, which
allows you to inject
a seed, so you
can have predictable results.
ANDREW BROGDON: For tests
that would be handy.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah, if
you go to random dart I think.
That should be here
in the utilities.
If I'm not mistaken.
Yeah, so essentially
we just wrap our random
in an iterator with the seed.
So if you use the same
seed, you will always
get the same random out
of it, which is very nice.
And then we use the
iterator to actually--
like, we consume it one by
one to produce the pipes.
So that's also very interesting.
But from the outside, again,
you have no idea where
these numbers are coming from.
Maybe you designed
a specific layout,
a specific level because you
want a challenge of some kind.
ANDREW BROGDON: People
could share seeds online
like they do with
some other games.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Yes, but even you
could create a list yourself.
It doesn't have to be random
because the iterable width
of the value is just injected.
Yeah, what else do we have?
The spices are also
interesting because it's
a lot harder than one
would think to load images.
In fact, there's an
image provider class,
which allows you-- oh
that's really not for my--
It allows you to
specify what image you
want to use without
actually loading it yet.
And so we do that.
We have a function that
takes the name of the thing
and tries to create an image
provider for it automatically.
ANDREW BROGDON: Using
this exact asset image?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah.
Yeah, and so again,
you need to inject
where to find the assets,
but then once you have that,
the whole system
is just completely
hooked up to easily find.
ANDREW BROGDON: So
I mean, you're not
doing anything like 1x, 2x,
3x image assets or anything
like that?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: No, because
since this is pixel art,
we are literally scaling
the pixels to like a x Is it
supposed to be a
little bit blocking.
And so it works perfectly well.
ANDREW BROGDON:
This is fascinating.
So where can people
go look at this code?
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Right now, nowhere.
On my laptop.
You have to know me.
But I really hope to push
this soon and finish it up.
The collisions need to be
taken care of, et cetera,
and there's a bunch of just
like that tutorial display when
you start the game
there's a counter.
ANDREW BROGDON: Of course.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: The
assets are already
done if you want to look at
them, and it's pretty cool.
In the Assets Directory.
ANDREW BROGDON: You have
a ton of stuff in here.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah
they're all changed.
Like if you go to
tutorial, it should be--
for example.
This is teaching you how to--
ANDREW BROGDON: Instruction.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Play the game.
Or if you make a
really good score,
then you get all the badges,
which look like coins.
Medal-- bronze medal, gold.
And this is, again,
dash titles, of course.
So yeah, I need to wire
this up, and it's going
to be on GitHub at some point.
ANDREW BROGDON: At some point.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Do you want to
look at the physics, last thing
that I just remembered.
ANDREW BROGDON: In physics.dart.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Of course.
Yeah, it's a flat gravity
simulation, obviously.
ANDREW BROGDON: As one would do.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Yeah,
and if you look at it,
it's really, really simple.
Like, there's not much to it.
This is the classic
equation for motion
that you learn in high
school, that's right?
ANDREW BROGDON: In pixels
per second squared.
So I think that's it
for our time with you.
But thank you so much.
This is a very unique app.
And so I'm looking forward
to this being on GitHub
just so we can
show it to people.
You're doing some things
here that not everyone
would have seen before,
including this guy.
But thank you to
Eugenio Marletti
for coming on the show.
We are going to get him and
our other two experts, and me,
behind this desk all at
once, and we're going
to answer some questions next.
So that's coming
up, but thank you.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Thank you.
Absolutely.
My pleasure.
ANDREW BROGDON: Are we ready?
All right, so in
this segment, we're
going to take some questions
that people have posted
to YouTube and to Twitter
using the hashtag #BoringShow
hashtag, and we're
going to answer them
with a lot of expert
help in the room.
All right, so first up coming
from Fishy Sushi, which
wins my personal award for
best Twitter handle of the day.
Am I mistaken, or this
is about our search
episode, which we just did.
Am I mistaken, or
are the suggestions
supposed to be a
list of past searches
when query is empty and
keywords related to the query.
That on Click, a suggestion
should become the query
used for fetching the results.
That is absolutely true.
In ours, because we
ended up because we only
had about 10 articles in
our list of search results--
if you've seen
that last episode--
we use the headlines
for the articles sort
of for both the listing of
results and suggestions.
But in practice, you
use a lot of apps.
They have a variety of
definitions for contextual help
for when you're doing a search.
For instance, maps.
You type something into maps
and you get, what are you
near to at this point.
Those might become
your keywords.
Or in Chrome, you
put something in
and you get the little
magnifying glass icon
that you get for like-- you
searched for this in the past,
and then like the
person half a mile
from you is searching
for this right now,
or these are the kinds of things
that people might be searching
for based on what
you've typed in.
So context depends a lot on
your app, and can be really--
it's up to you, really, what
you think the user might
want in that situation.
Anybody have searching
in their apps right now?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: No searching.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yeah, I have one.
ANDREW BROGDON: You
have one with search?
PAWAN KUMAR: I'm
using in the same way.
I have to show some
solutions as well.
And when people such
about, so I have like I
kind of ecommerce app
where people actually
search for products.
And then we show some bar
codes with their product name.
So that is showing in
the search results,
as well as in the solutions.
And then we bold
those connectors,
depending on how the
person is searching.
ANDREW BROGDON: So it
depends sort of on the user
and what they have
given you so far.
It totally depends on
the use codes, I believe.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Don't
do what Twitter does,
which is you start typing,
something shows up.
You're about to click in
then it just goes away.
ANDREW BROGDON: A lot of
details to get the UI right.
All right.
So let's go on to
our second one.
This is from Priyansh Parmar.
And it says, any tutorial on how
to use Google Maps in Flutter?
This is something we get a lot.
And so I'm going to go ahead and
pull up our plug-ins repo here.
So if you've never been
here, highly recommended it.
Flutter/plugins.
We've shown it a bunch of times
on the Boring Show before.
And we go into packages.
And where are we?
Google Maps Flutter.
So I get that a lot.
We're looking at this plug-in.
So this is not yet
published to pub.
It is not yet ready
for prime time,
but you can't go into this
package and take a look around.
If
Because we get this
question a lot.
You know, what's
going on with maps?
How is it coming?
This is a better answer to
that question than anything
I can tell you because
it's more up to date.
You can actually see
the code, and see
what's been implemented.
We also have-- if I go
in to Flutter/samples.
we also have a map sample that's
starting to land right now
called Place Tracker, which
the very talented Kenzie
Schmall up in
Portland is working on
for the deverall team.
And so this is
something that if you
want to see how the Google map
API is going to look in an app
when it's finished
and how you're
going to code against it, this
is a great place to start.
She's done some really,
really great work on this.
It involves placing markers
and things like that.
Setting the map type from
terrain to roads and things
like that.
So yeah, if you have questions
about maps, don't mess around.
Just go straight to the code.
PAWAN KUMAR: I'm going to make
a YouTube tutorial on this.
So don't worry.
ANDREW BROGDON: You guys,
any experience using maps?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Actually, no.
IIRO KRANKKA: Same for me.
PAWAN KUMAR: I just used for
one of the tutorial only,
and that was a plugin which
was showing these static maps
rather than as a widget.
ANDREW BROGDON: These
are not the static maps.
These are using the
platform widgets to--
you can manipulate the
map, you can tap on things.
PAWAN KUMAR: I guess there
are many guys who are waiting
for like this particular--
EUGENIO MARLETTI: This is
really close to theater.
ANDREW BROGDON: This is why we
get a lot of questions on it.
So if you'd like to
know where things are,
the code is the
best place to go.
That's true of a lot of
things in Flutter, actually.
All right.
Let's see another question.
And this from Paul Shaw.
Question: can Block
be used together
with scoped model in
Flutter, or are they
not meant to be used that way?
PAWAN KUMAR: I have used it.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Absolutely illegal.
ANDREW BROGDON: It's legal.
We've determined it.
So have you ever mixed the two?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: You can, sure.
It depends how your
app is structured.
There might be
encapsulated parts
that you want to
handle differently.
And maybe you have
different teams
working in a different way.
Like I don't see why
not, if it works for you.
IIRO KRANKKA: But I would say
that if you use a scope mode
and Blocks together, and you're
meaning to do a web app as
well, then you're going to--
because scope model is really
tightly tied to Flutter.
That's not going to
work in web, as well.
But this actual issue
about splitting this scope
model so that it would
work in web and Flutter,
but that's not done right now.
ANDREW BROGDON: Interesting.
PAWAN KUMAR: I have mostly
used a block pattern only,
but in some use cases, I have
used scope model as well,
for some of this.
ANDREW BROGDON: Scope
model is just incredibly
handy for anything small.
If you just need a
little bit of app state,
it is so easy to use.
We use it in our
examples all the time
because it's just
very uncomplicated.
But yeah, I think we have a lot
of different state management
approaches.
We got Redux back
here, Block over here.
I have Free Block that
I wrote because I just
make mistakes like that.
Probably all of us have used
scope model at some point.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
Definitely a Redux fan,
but if you have UI State,
especially, and it's something
that you domain logic
doesn't really care about,
using the scope model is
actually a really good way
to propagate stuff.
PAWAN KUMAR: And if you don't
have to do a lot of stuff
inside your application-- if
it's a very small application,
then you don't have
to use anything
like Redux, even Block.
So scope model
works pretty well.
IIRO KRANKKA: It's really
simple to get started with.
PAWAN KUMAR: Another
widget we're just
kind of just rapping with it
and it's working perfectly.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
Yeah, we can spend 20 minutes
talking about state management.
So Paul Sean actually had
another question later on,
and it was, I heard
you guys mentioned
that in Dart explicitly
giving the type
of a variable like bool or
int is better for the IDE.
How does it affect the
performance of a Flutter app?
When should I type stuff?
There's the final
keyword there's
the viewer keyword you
can let the compiler,
the static analysis,
determine the type for you.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: But the point
is that the type is always
defined at compile time.
So in the end,
performance wise it
doesn't matter, as long as
you resolve to the same type.
ANDREW BROGDON:
As long as you do
have something that
gives the compiler,
and you don't end
up with dynamic.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Because I
think you were mentioning this
before.
If you end up being
dynamic all the time,
then that could be a problem.
ANDREW BROGDON: So if you're
using a stream builder,
for example, there's a type
parameter that goes onto it.
Stream builder, bracket int
or string or list of string.
Whatever the payload
is for your stream.
If you don't give
that to Dart, it just
goes OK, string builder dynamic.
This will take whatever
anybody gives it.
But you also don't
get a typed builder,
so you run into
an issue when you
go to build your widgets that
you don't know what data you're
going to get, because
the compiler doesn't know
what data it's going to get.
And so usually I
ended up catching it
if I've done something that way.
Like if I've left
myself in a dynamic,
like I failed to give the
compiler enough information
to resolve the type.
I run into a later inconvenience
and notice it right away.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
It's like a virus.
It spreads.
PAWAN KUMAR: If you're going
difficult to actually figuring
it out at that time.
And I personally feel that
for developer experience,
it's kind of good practice to
actually specify those types.
So you like generally
manually typing.
IIRO KRANKKA: I
would say it actually
helps pull request
reviews sometimes
if you're not inside of
your ID, you can see that,
OK, this is going--
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Now we're
getting into the realm of--
PAWAN KUMAR: I say about that.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
In other languages,
type inference works so well
that sometimes you really
don't want to specify the
type because it almost
doesn't matter.
In the context of that piece
of code, if it compiles
it's fine, essentially.
There is an analyzer flag
to disallow allow having
the compiler automatically--
ANDREW BROGDON:
That's a good point.
If any of you are
considering becoming
a contributor to the Flutter SDK
itself, or one of the packages,
they actually have
that flag set.
And so they prefer types
in pretty much anywhere
you can put one,
including in Landis.
IIRO KRANKKA: I've been
doing a couple of PRs,
and they actually--
you guys actually
use unspecified types
manually for some reason.
I don't know why.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: It's analyzer
strong mode, implicit cuts,
false.
And implicit dynamic, false.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Implicit dynamic is
that what I was thinking
of, but implicit cast, too.
PAWAN KUMAR: I actually used in
one of the versions when there
was an issue with the
.organ or something.
I had to use it.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: I like
being strict in my types.
It helps.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yes.
All right.
So one last question.
This is from QuEdAdZa,
judging by the capitalization.
I'm interested in two topics,
Flutter internationalizing
and map support for Flutter.
And so map support, we kind of
covered already, but real quick
who's done anything with
internationalization?
Because that's
not something I've
gotten into yet personally.
PAWAN KUMAR: He's the guy.
IIRO KRANKKA: So I've done
that a couple of times,
and I keep notes for myself.
So it's kind of an
involved process to do.
And in my [INAUDIBLE]
app, in the core module,
that's actually a
sample to do that.
But I would say that the docs
are kind of scattered around.
PAWAN KUMAR: Yes, correct.
IIRO KRANKKA: You've
probably actually--
PAWAN KUMAR: I have actually
used it just for one language
only.
I actually can watch
it from English
to Hindi for Flutter UI kit.
So I actually used it, but
it's maybe kind of maybe
difficult from when you're
reading from the documentation,
it's kind of difficult
to understand.
IIRO KRANKKA: It's kind
of similar to like how
QT handles the internalization.
So you basically like you
defer defined your mistakes,
and then you use a tool to
center right those ARB files.
And then you upload those
somewhere and translate those
and then get those
back to your app.
But I would definitely
want to have
some kind of hold your
hand guide around this,
because you don't
do that so often,
so you kind of
forget it every time.
And then you have to relearn it.
PAWAN KUMAR: It takes some time.
I could not give that
much time to that project.
I mean, this thing can
be improved, for sure.
EUGENIO MARLETTI:
STID could help.
IIRO KRANKKA: Dueling
would be awesome for you.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Like I said, we're
going to run into this
with the Vox Day app
pretty soon because we're
going to want to add
internationalization for that.
And so that's something
the deverall team is
going to run into,
and we will probably
start making more cohesive
guides for it at that time.
Because it's an important issue
if you're-- everybody wants
an international audience.
All right, so that's
our questions.
And that's our show, actually.
So thank you to everybody
for being on here.
PAWAN KUMAR: Thanks to everyone.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Yeah, again, if you
would like to post questions
for us, please do that.
You can use the Boring
Show hashtag on Twitter.
You can respond in the comments
to this video themselves.
We look at those all the time.
We try to answer them, both
in the comments and here.
PAWAN KUMAR: Maybe we'll not
answer it together next time,
but separately we
can answer, right?
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Ask for
us to come back to the show.
It's very important.
PAWAN KUMAR: That's
very important.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
So thanks to you guys.
And thanks to all of you that
made it through the episode
with us.
We'll see you next time.
EUGENIO MARLETTI: Bye.